[Music]
for six months now millions of americans
have been working from home
some companies including twitter have
told employees they can keep working
remotely
forever but there's also an effort to
prove offices can safely reopen led
largely by the people renting them out
as brook silva braga found it one high
in manhattan building
that has led to lots of new procedures
but only a few clear
answers okay 10 grand central
welcome good to be here even if mark's
realty ceo
craig deidelsweig is your host a visit
to 10 grand central
starts with a temperature check
entry to the building is now controlled
by an app
i don't have to touch anything is the
idea so through your app right now it's
already beeping i hear it
yeah that's how you get onto there what
does it look like to marry the latest
recommendations for indoor spaces
with a glossy brand of office real
estate we wanted to put up some
plexiglass to just allow for some
separation
as diego zweig showed us what he'd come
up with we've noticed that the changes
mostly fall into two buckets
the first focusing on the air starting
with the ventilation system
so behind there we change all the
filters to be more robust filtering
occurring here and then behind the
filter is a uv light
and that light we believe is killing the
virus we believe it's killing the virus
since fresh air is even safer patios
have been rearranged as conference rooms
to the extent you can be outside that's
what people are doing
the second category of change is the
surfaces and the idea here is you'll
touch
almost none of them the bathroom door is
open is it meant to stay open
yes we used to have faucets that you
were touched now it's touchless
we're also looking into having our
coffee makers cappuccino makers be
touchless as well
really yeah we have not had much success
on that
because they don't exist we found one
and it's about twenty thousand dollars
which is just
you know that's very expensive
cappuccino and a basic
question hung in that purified air above
all those empty desks
is an office even one like this really
safe
in rochester minnesota a team of
scientists is working to figure that out
not only in the petri dish but also in a
very unusual kind of laboratory
looks a lot like an office it looks
exactly like an office
but this actually is a lab with over 700
different
sensors the well living lab was built to
measure the impact of
changes to the indoor environment actor
stacy rizza of the mayo clinic
gave us a zoom style tour we can control
different parts of the ventilation
system and monitor air quality with
people in the office
and in the time of coronavirus like
diadel's wide
they're focused on surfaces and air this
is called a blam
nebulizer dr chris hogan an aerosol
scientist from the university of
minnesota
will track how changes to the office
layout and ventilation
change how droplets travel these
droplets are now dispersing throughout
the room
hogan says we already know sitting near
the fresh air of a ventilation duct
might help but more important is
learning two things about your office
how often all the air is recycled
something called the air change rate it
should be about seven times an hour
and the efficiency of the air filters
measured by their mirv
rating hopefully a 14 or higher should
we have all our windows open
it doesn't hurt but before doing that i
would want to consult with
the hvac engineers who designed the
space if that sounds like a
contradiction it could be because
so many covet questions still await
clear
answers everything lighting up is the
virus in the cell for instance dr
rizza is testing how a virus like
covid19
spreads on different types of surfaces
and how well different types of
disinfectant work
but those experiments like all of them
at the well living lab
are still just being set up we've got
millions and millions of infections
and we've got experiments that just seem
to be starting that's frustrating to the
public
it is frustrating to the public but i
will say as an
infectious disease doctor that the
knowledge we have
about sars cove too in seven months
probably took
five to ten years if not longer to get
that
knowledge from hiv we all want answers
now but science just doesn't work that
way
real estate moves faster in the interim
what we're doing is we actually have a
wipe here
and with imperfect knowledge craig
dietlesweig is welcoming back tenants
but admits there may never be as many
occupied desks as there once were
what we're finding now is that people
want more elbow rooms
in this new space he's building out
about half the workers will have their
own
enclosed office before it would have
been
nearly all cubicles you were going to
fit 30 in here
now i can only fit 15 is the rent the
same the rent's the same
people are just using the space
differently but will they use it
well about 20 percent of workers came to
attend grand central this week
deidel zweig says he expects more next
week
for cbs this morning saturday brook
silva braca new york
so fascinating i mean as dr ages said
earlier the science will win in the end
and will show us the way it just
is going to take time yeah it's going to
take a little while i also am looking at
that i don't mean to be debbie downer
but it's the question of how much does
that cost if you have to redo so many of
the buildings in that vein and one of
the big issues is whether these whether
the landlords are going to lower rents
for all these people i mean because
their places are empty and they can't
pay i doubt it
yeah i doubt that some compromise there